foreign
Lisa is in Indianapolis hi Lisa welcome
to the Ramsey Show
hi oh my goodness
I'm really nervous that's okay we've
never lost a patient what's up
okay okay good
um so um just to get to the point here
about 15 years ago my husband took out a
HELOC how many years ago
about 15 15 years ago he took out a
HELOC okay uh-huh for an investment
opportunity
and the last few years it hasn't been
paying dividends
it's with his company
and we started Jade's Class A few weeks
ago and I love her she's awesome and
we're we're going through the baby steps
and I just feel like we're so out of
order because we had our house paid off
um and then
and then he I'm sorry
um did this investment opportunity and
now I feel like
um
I'm a little bitter and I'm having a
hard time being on board to pay this off
together because I'm just upset about it
because where were you 15 years ago
I had two babies and I said I don't
agree with it and you signed the papers
anyway
no I didn't sign any papers yes you did
you don't get a HELOC on someone's
personal residence without spouse's
signature
okay
and um
well I
it doesn't matter now there's a HELOC on
your house okay uh but
um I yeah I might matter I don't know uh
okay so what do you want to do
um I don't know I was motivated to get
um how much is the debt
it's up to 283
000. what does your husband make the
name debt we have
about we probably bring in about ten
thousand a month what was his investment
into his company he he bought into a a
partnership or what
um so it was a family-owned company and
he had initially had shares with the
company and then when it sold
to a private firm he made all this money
off the shares where did that money go
he
um he reinvested 500 000 first he paid
off our house which is great
and then the rest of it about 500 000 he
reinvested in the company
and then I guess he was so excited he
decided oh well you know we're getting a
dividend of six definitely the
investment into the new company is in
what form
is a publicly traded company or what no
it's not it's
um
he still works there
so what percentage of this company does
he own
I don't
know what are the rules to get out of it
can you sell them yes
I asked them that too and he said oh no
we can't sell them and I said well let's
talk to per let's talk to whoever's in
charge of this and see what we can do
yeah
to sell it yeah
so that's kind of on his assignment
because you know when we started this
class A few weeks ago it's not going to
do with the class it's got to do it's
got to just do with common sense
we need to clear we need to clear up
this mess you've made and you're playing
Russian roulette with our house
it ain't cool dude
it's not have you shared with him your
feelings about this strongly saying I
don't feel safe I want this deck gone
is he actually listening to that or is
he going well just trust me trust me I
got this
well when I bring it up
you'll either leave the room or last
week when we're listening to Jade's
class I just started crying and talking
about it
and I don't and the thing is he's like
the nicest person in the world he's not
like a jerk he doesn't go out and buy
things for himself or anything oh I I
beg to differ
yeah I think he bought a lot of stuff
for himself like five hundred thousand
dollars worth
and I'll put in your home at risk
yeah so yeah we need to liquidate this
it's not hey it's not paying dividends
it's not working uh so I'm kind of work
I'm kind of worried about the quality of
the company at this stage of the game
um and whether you're ever going to get
a half a million dollars out of it or
not and B uh you want to get your house
paid off and uh that you know he
basically borrowed on your home to
invest in a business that he's a
minority shareholder in
which is just dangerous
can be
that's just dangerous because he's got
no vote he can't you know if you don't
have if you're not a majority
shareholder meaning 51 you don't control
the outcomes of the company
and so other people vote your prosperity
in or out
right and that's what's happening here I
can I can tell by the way you've
structured this
conversation so yeah he needs to uh that
this sweet man needs to get his money
out of his company and pay off his home
and
um and never sign his wife's name again
without her without having a power of
attorney
um because I don't unless unless Indiana
has different laws than most States uh
you don't get a home equity loan without
both spousals both spouses signing on a
property on your personal residence now
you could do it on a investment property
in some states but you can't do it on
your personal residence Title Company
won't cover it so now Dave I've heard
you talk about agreeing with your spouse
on financial decisions and you and
Sharon do this so if you say hey I want
to invest this money over here and
Sharon has a strong feeling as you say
yeah does it just not happening what's
the conversation we argue about it until
I'm right but you know I'll argue about
it until she's right but you know we
come to a conclusion but we're not when
in doubt don't
is the rule and and so uh and you know
these days Lisa what you're what your
role is is the same as Sharon's because
this is the type of crap I did in the
old days I'm not signing her name but uh
uh I'm not 100 sure he did that but I'm
kind of thinking he did
um but the uh uh but this idea of I'm
gonna do this this is the right thing
and she's got two kids and she's like
whatever you want to do go ahead and she
would say like whatever you want to do
honey which is Southern for you wreck it
by yourself Bubba and then I'm gonna
make fun of you that's what that means
and so uh you know no we need to have a
meeting of the minds we need to be and
Lisa Your Role from this point forward
is speak up loudly
you have a voice you have a vote and
both of you get a vote and if both of
you don't place your votes you stand a
much higher probability of losing money
on things and buying the wrong things at
the wrong times